and as set forth in the report after
that investigation if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so we did not however make a
determination as to whether the
President did commit a crime the
introduction to the volume 2 of our
report explains that decision it
explains that under long-standing
department policy a president president
cannot be charged with a federal crime
while he is in office that is
unconstitutional even if the charge is
kept under seal and hidden from public
view that too is prohibited the special
counsels office is part of the
Department of Justice and by regulation
it was bound by that department policy
charging the president with a crime was
therefore not an option
we could consider the department's
written opinion explaining the policy
makes several important points that
further informed our handling of the
obstruction investigation those points
are summarized in our report and I will
describe two of them for you first the
opinion explicitly explicitly permits
the investigation of a sitting president
because it is important to preserve
evidence well memories are fresh and
documents available among other things
that evidence could be used if there
were co-conspirators who could be
charged now and second the opinion says
that the Constitution requires a process
other than the criminal justice system
to formally accuse a sitting president
of wrongdoing and beyond Department
policy we were guided by principles of
fairness it would be unfair to
potentially it would be unfair to
potentially accuse somebody of a crime
when there can be no court resolution of
the actual charge so that was Justice
Department policy those were the
principles under which we operated and
from them we concluded that
would would not reach a determination
one way or the other about whether the
president committed a crime